what if it doesn't work out I made a
video not too long ago called ignore the
non-believers and in this video I talk
about the people who doubt you the
people who hate on your ideas of people
who make you feel like you're never
going to make it I call these people now
little man we all have a little man in
our life who's trying to hold us back
tell us all the reasons why something is
not going to work out you can't listen a
little man and I got a response from one
of my youtube viewers love you guys
Elle Chen who wrote in to say what if it
doesn't work out and this is a real fear
for a lot of entrepreneurs when you're
first getting started here's what you
have to know about success as an
entrepreneur success doesn't look like
this
okay success is not just a straight line
of success it's it's a bunch of failures
before you take off and if you look at
every business that's started the idea
that you start with is not the idea that
you end with you're going to have to
change your product your service your
approach your marketing you have to
change so much as you grow your company
and all of those things can be seen as
as failures and so for me
the biggest question comes down to how
badly do you really want this are you
trying to do something important or not
is this is this core to you or not are
you passionate about this or not because
if you're not if you're doing this just
for the money
and you're stuck in this little wave of
ups and downs and failures before you
hit it if you're stuck and all that
failure you're gonna quit it's it's
there's nothing driving you to keep
going right the money is not enough of
the driver to help you keep going you're
going to quit and you could say it
didn't work out but if you partially
believe in what you're doing and and
what you're trying to build is important
for you and your community and your
family if it's that important for you
then you'll ride through all those crazy
ups and downs and big failures to make
it through to that success you look at
companies look I encourage you find your
favorite big famous entrepreneur and
look at how they got started it was not
like this it was tons of
what if I'm not going to make it tons of
failures I think about my own company my
first software company I had I was 19
years old I I thought I'm going to make
it of course I'm going to make it you
know I had two great partners I had you
know university training I was going to
make this thing happen I've done my
research I'm a hard worker and I spent a
whole summer working on my plan this is
my marketing plan how we're going to go
to market how we're going to make
millions of dollars from this software
and I was really excited about it
it has to work and we launched and it
didn't work at all
nothing it was a embarrassing failure
and a huge pill to swallow
and it made me think about quitting and
and I could have thought just like you
are right now what if I don't make it
like I did not make it I planned I
worked and I didn't make it and at that
point I had to decide either I quit this
thing because it's too hard because I
don't know how it's going to work out
because I don't have the answers because
I didn't have as much confidence in
myself anymore or I keep going because
what I'm doing here is important because
I believe in it and I'm going to find a
way to make it work and I almost quit it
wasn't like of course going to keep
going that's a hard decision I almost
quit and I told my partner that I quit I
told him I was out Anna and I I was
crying for 20 minutes afterwards and
barely slept that night I told him I
quit on the next day I got up and I
wouldn't back to work because what I was
doing was important and it was that
driving force that kept me going that
this is important work that we're doing
and it needs to continue and even though
I don't know how it's going to work out
I'm going to keep working till I find a
way for it to work out so what if it
doesn't work out it's not going to work
out at the start it won't
it's just how motivated are you to keep
seeing this thing through until it does
work out and ignore the little man and
ignore people ridiculing you and saying
it's never going to happen those people
don't count
if it's important enough for you you'll
find the way and it will work at belief
so those of you watching like the video
give it a thumbs up below that stuff
makes me want to make more videos for
you please leave a comment let me know
what you think I love seeing the
comments is the best part of my day you
have a question leave it below - I'll
make a video response and if you want to
see more videos like this click on my
face subscribe to the channel and you'll
see more videos thank you so much and
I'll see you soon